Romana Roo is the central city of  trading back when ships from Valencia  would anchor in Nauru children would  greet the merchants and fireworks would  light the skies Nauru was a thriving  city of sailors and merchants and  crowded areas were guarded by  mercenaries little did they know what  had arrived could any of these people  know of the illusion stove  it is the mythical stone of the ancient  civilization but the dark power it  possesses has been hidden by that very  civilization at last the illusion was  uncovered a mysterious black smoke rose  up over the ridge it seemed to know  exactly where it was headed  Chico 100 the elisions told be  perforated  people started to disappear all across  Omaha  in the end  there was no one left and that day was  soon forgotten  you